welcome to the hubermann lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine today we are
discussing alcohol one of the most
commonly consumed substances on the
planet earth i should mention that both
humans and non-human animals consume
alcohol either for recreational purposes
because they like the feeling that it
gives them or for medicinal purposes or
for other purposes that we'll discuss
we are of course going to discuss the
effects of alcohol on our biology
ranging from its effects on individual
cells on organs and organ systems in our
brain and body we are also going to
discuss the effects of the effects of
alcohol
that is what being inebriated really
does to our thinking and our behavior
and how it does it and we are going to
address what seems to be one of the more
common questions out there which is
whether or not
low to moderate amounts of drinking are
better for our health than zero alcohol
consumption at all
and of course we will talk about severe
alcohol intake binge drinking we will
also talk about hangover and what
science says about ways to reduce the
effects of hangover either by doing
things that are inoculatory meaning
before you drink or while you drink as
well as things to do if you happen to
have a hangover we will discuss some of
the genetic differences for alcohol and
alcoholism
and we will discuss
alcohol consumption in young people and
how that can be especially detrimental
for reasons that i think are going to be
quite surprising to most of you my goal
is that by the end of today's episode
you will have a thorough understanding
of what alcohol does to your brain and
body and that you will be able to make
informed decisions as to whether or not
you should be consuming zero absolutely
no alcohol small to moderate amounts of
alcohol and again we'll define exactly
what that means small to moderate
amounts and if you or somebody else that
you know is consuming excessive amounts
of alcohol that are clearly detrimental
to your health some of the better routes
and resources that you can use in order
to remove that dependence and or
consumption i'd like to preface all of
that by saying that today's discussion
is really geared toward giving you
information it is not about judging
alcohol intake or lack of alcohol intake
i just want you to be able to make the
most informed decision about alcohol
possible i'm pleased to announce that
the huberman lab podcast is now
partnered with momentous supplements we
partnered with momentous for several
important reasons first of all they ship
internationally because we know that
many of you are located outside of the
united states second of all and perhaps
most important the quality of their
supplements is second to none both in
terms of purity and precision of the
amounts of the ingredients
third we've really emphasized
supplements that are single ingredient
supplements and that are supplied in
dosages that allow you to build a
supplementation protocol
that's optimized for cost that's
optimized for effectiveness and that you
can add things and remove things from
your protocol in a way that's really
systematic and scientific if you'd like
to see the supplements that we've
partnered with momentus on you can go to
livemomentus.com
huberman there you'll see those
supplements and just keep in mind that
we are constantly expanding the library
of supplements available through
momentous on a regular basis again
that's livemomentus.com
huberman before we get into today's
content in detail i just want to answer
a commonly asked question about alcohol
consumption and the brain and the
question that so often comes up is
whether or not low to moderate amounts
of alcohol so maybe one drink a day or
one or two drinks a day kind of thing
whether or not that is bad for your
brain
in particular whether or not it causes
degeneration of neurons or nerve cells
now the reason that question comes up so
often
is because for many years it's been
known that high levels of alcohol
consumption so 12 to 24 drinks per week
or more
is certainly causing neurodegeneration
in particular of the so-called neocortex
the outer layers of the brain that house
associative memories that house our
ability to think and plan that house our
ability to regulate our more primitive
drives according to context etc
so to make very clear
drinking a lot so having you know three
or four drinks per night
every night of the week is clearly bad
for the brain a recent study however
finally addressed the question of
whether or not low to moderate amounts
of alcohol consumption can cause brain
degeneration
the title of the study
is associations between alcohol
consumption and gray and white matter
volumes in the uk biobank the united
kingdom biobank
first of all gray matter are the neurons
that's the so-called cell bodies that
house the genome of the cells etc and
white matter is the connections the
fibers the so-called axons of neurons
and it it's called white matter because
that
that tissue is surrounded by a fatty
tissue called myelin which allows nerve
cells to communicate with each other
very quickly so what this study did is
it looked at the brains both the gray
matter and the white matter of more than
30 000 any more than 35 000 generally
healthy middle aged and older adults in
the united kingdom who were drinking
various amounts of alcohol what they
found was that even for people that were
drinking low to moderate amounts of
alcohol so one or two drinks per day
there was evidence of
thinning of the neocortex so loss of
neurons in the neocortex and other brain
regions
and i don't say this in order to cause
alarm i tell you this because they are
important data
because they reveal
and indeed answer the question that has
been burning for so long whether or not
chronic alcohol intake
can disrupt the brain even if the
chronic intake is very low now we should
talk about what the word chronic means
because many people when they hear the
word chronic think
high levels of whatever intake okay so
they think five drinks a night or ten
drinks a night or people drinking every
night now in this study they looked at
people who on average were drinking one
or two drinks per night so that could be
14 drinks on the weekend
it could be one drink per night it could
be seven drinks on friday in other words
on average one or two drinks per night
and i think many people out there are
drinking somewhere between one and two
drinks per
night or day of the week on average so
that would be seven to 14 drinks per
week so this is an important study
because it says that if you're consuming
even just seven glasses of wine across
the week it's likely that there is going
to be some degeneration of your brain in
response to that alcohol intake
although as mentioned earlier we will
talk about some of the things that can
inoculate against some of that neuronal
loss for those of you that are
interested in reading the study in more
detail we've put a link to it in the
show note captions before we begin i'd
like to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme i'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is levels
levels is a program that lets you see
how different foods affect your health
by giving you real-time feedback on your
diet using a continuous glucose monitor
one of the most important features of
our immediate feelings of well-being and
our ability to focus and think and move
and have energy as well as our long-term
health
are our blood glucose levels that is our
blood sugar levels and that's because
all the cells and tissues of our body
and especially neurons nerve cells rely
on glucose for fuel
i realize some of you out there are
ketogenic and yes you can use ketones
for fuel but the vast majority of people
are using glucose for fuel in their
cells
if you want to maintain energy and focus
throughout the day you want to keep that
blood glucose steady and you don't want
it ever to spike or to drop too much so
you need to understand how different
foods and indeed how different
activities impact your blood glucose i
started using levels about a year ago as
a way to understand how different foods
and exercise and supplements and
combinations of food and exercise and
even sequencing like when i do what how
that affects my blood glucose levels
it's been tremendously informative it's
completely reshaped when i exercise how
i exercise when i eat relative to
exercise etc so if you're interested in
learning more about levels and trying a
continuous glucose monitor yourself go
to levels dot link
huberman again that's levels dot
levels.link
huberman today's episode is also brought
to us by eight sleep eight sleep makes
smart mattress covers with cooling
heating and sleep tracking capacity i've
talked many times on the podcast about
the fact that getting a great night's
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and all forms of
performance and one of the key variables
in getting a great night's sleep is
making sure that your sleeping
environment is the right temperature
indeed your brain and body have to drop
by one to three degrees in order to get
into sleep and to stay in deep sleep
throughout the night
if your room is too hot or if you're
running too warm you will wake up in
fact that is why you wake up in the
morning
with eight sleep you can adjust the
temperature of your mattress in your
overall sleeping environment and
customize that to you i started using
eight sleep some time ago
and it's just been a total game changer
i programmed mine so that there's a
subtle drop in the temperature of my
mattress at the beginning of the night
and then gets progressively cooler and
then it heats up toward morning even has
this nice little vibrate feature so it
wakes me up by vibrating uh the mattress
a little bit and of course that mattress
is warming and warming is the way that
we wake up if you'd like to try eight
sleep go to 8sleep.com huberman check
out their pro pod cover and save up to
150 at checkout eight sleep currently
ships in the usa canada and the united
kingdom again that's eight sleep.com
huberman to save 150
at checkout today's episode is also
brought to us by roka roka makes
eyeglasses and sunglasses that are of
the absolute highest quality and they
also have some unique characteristics
the company was founded by two
all-american swimmers from stanford and
everything about roca eyeglasses and
sunglasses were designed with
performance in mind roka eyeglasses and
sunglasses can be worn while running or
cycling if you get sweaty they won't
fall off your face and they're extremely
lightweight in fact most of the time i
can't even remember that i'm wearing
them i wear roka eyeglasses when i read
at night so i wear their readers and i
wear sunglasses at various times
throughout the day the great thing about
roka eyeglasses and sunglasses is that
even though they were designed for
athletic performance they have a
terrific aesthetic so unlike a lot of
so-called performance glasses that make
people look like cyborgs in my opinion
eyeglasses and sunglasses are the sort
you could wear out to dinner that you
could wear to work they have a terrific
aesthetic if you'd like to try roka
eyeglasses or sunglasses you can go to
roca that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
again that's roka roka.com and enter the
code huberman at checkout let's talk
about alcohol and let's just acknowledge
that human beings have been consuming
alcohol for thousands of years if you
look at the archaeological evidence from
mesopotamia you'll find that 5000 years
ago people had wine vessels or if you
want to know when people first started
distilling alcohol much to people
surprised that did not first take place
in ireland and that's not a joke about
the irish that you'll see a lot of
claims online that the irish were the
first to distill alcohol but in fact
they were not it was the chinese that
were the first to distill alcohol and
that took place in china in the first
century
alcohol has been used for nutritional
purposes so there are cultures that
believe and indeed still believe that
the calories and alcohol are useful
although later we'll talk about how
alcohol calories are indeed empty
calories and what an empty calorie
really is why it's called empty
alcohol has been used for medicinal
purposes because indeed it does kill
bacteria and as you'll soon find out the
fact that it kills bacteria because that
is absolutely true
it also kills the good bacteria in your
gut and the destruction of that good
bacteria in your gut can lead to things
like leaky gut syndrome and has all
sorts of issues and there are ways to
deal with those issues and we'll talk
about those so alcohol has been used for
medicinal purposes it's been used to
clean surfaces it's used in my
laboratory in order to make up
so-called reagents to do our experiments
but most humans have been consuming
alcohol in order to change their
internal state in order to feel
differently than they would otherwise
that feeling of being drunk or
inebriated or tipsy or lightheaded
is something that many not all but many
humans seem to enjoy and pursue even
though
typically
it leads to a feeling of
being
less happy
less motivated more stressed etc when
the alcohol wears off that's pretty
incredible right i mean we're talking
about a substance that people have been
highly motivated to pursue that are
still highly motivated to pursue to
create and to consume that they'll spend
money on
and
that's despite the fact that it makes
them feel good and then it makes them
feel lousy now some of you might be
saying well i drink but i don't drink to
excess and therefore i don't feel lousy
i feel good when i drink and then it
wears off and it allows me to get
through my evening and then the next
morning i'm ready to go okay
that very well may be true i believe
those people
and as i mentioned the beginning of the
episode i'm not here to demonize alcohol
in any way
but i do want to point out what alcohol
is and how it creates the effects that
it does
and then i want to talk about what those
effects are when you engage in consuming
alcohol
even as
often as one or two nights per week or
let's say you're just somebody who has a
drink or two on friday maybe a few more
on saturday or maybe you're somebody who
consumes all your alcohol one night per
week or one night per month we'll talk
about how that's affecting your biology
so
let's address what alcohol is and how it
affects the cells and tissues and organs
of your body then we'll take a look at
some of the epidemiology that is how
many people are consuming alcohol and
how much they're drinking and then
you'll be able i think to get a good
sense of how the alcohol that you're
drinking if you're drinking any at all
is impacting your brain and body and the
choices you might want to make about how
and when to drink alcohol or even if you
want to eliminate alcohol altogether
okay so some basic chemistry and biology
of alcohol and again i'll make this very
clear even if you don't have a chemistry
and biology background
because of the structure of alcohol it
is what's called both water soluble and
fat soluble translated into what's
meaningful for you what that means is
when you drink alcohol it can pass into
all the cells and tissues of your body
it has no trouble just passing right
into those cells so unlike a lot of
substances and drugs that actually
attach to the surface of cells to
receptors as they're called little
parking spots and then trigger a bunch
of
downstream like domino cascades of
effects alcohol actually has its own
direct effects on cells because it can
really just pass into those cells
so it's water and fat soluble and the
fact that it can pass into so many
organs and cells so easily is really
what explains its damaging effects
i should mention that there are three
main types of alcohol there's isopropyl
methyl and ethyl alcohol and only the
last one ethyl alcohol or ethanol
is fit for human consumption however
it is still toxic okay it produces
substantial stress and damage to cells
i'd love to be able to tell you
otherwise but that's just a fact
ethanol produces substantial damage to
cells and it does that because when you
ingest ethanol it has to be converted
into something else because it is toxic
to the body and there's a molecule
inside of all of us called nad and you
may have heard of nid because it's quite
popular there's a lot of discussion
about nad in the longevity literature
right now nad is present in all our
cells from birth until death the levels
of nad tend to go down across the
lifespan there are ideas that increasing
levels of nad may extend lifespan a lot
of that is still controversial or at
least we should say is ongoing in terms
of the research but nonetheless when you
ingest ethanol
nad and related biochemical pathways are
involved in converting that ethanol into
something called acetylaldehyde it's
broken down into acetylaldehyde and if
you thought ethanol was bad acetyl
aldehyde is particularly bad acetyl
aldehyde is poison it will kill cells it
damages and kills cells and it is
indiscriminate as to which cells it
damages and kills
now
that's a problem obviously and the body
deals with that problem
by using another component of the nad
biochemical pathway to convert
acetylaldehyde into something called
acetate
acetate is actually something that your
body can use as fuel and that
process of going from ethanol to
acetylaldehyde to acetate
does involve the production of a toxic
molecule right again acetyl aldehyde is
really toxic and nad and if we want to
get technical it's the nad to nadh
ratio and that
chemical step is the rate limiting step
to ethanol's metabolism what does that
mean for you what that means is that if
your body can't do this conversion of
ethanol to acetyl aldehyde to acetate
fast enough well acetylaldehyde will
build up in your body and cause more
damage
so it's important that your body be able
to do this conversion very quickly
and the place where it does that is
within the liver and cells within the
liver are very good at this conversion
process
but they are cells and they are exposed
to the acetylaldehyde in the conversion
process and so cells within the liver
really take a beating
in the alcohol metabolism
events so the key thing to understand
here is that when you ingest alcohol you
are yes ingesting a poison and that
poison is converted into an even worse
poison in your body and some percentage
of that worst poison is converted into a
form of calories that you can use to
generate energy generate atp
and the reason why alcohol is considered
empty calories is because that entire
process is very metabolically costly but
there's no real nutritive value of the
calories that it creates you can use it
for immediate energy but it can't be
stored in any kind of meaningful or
beneficial way it doesn't provide any
vitamins it doesn't provide any amino
acids it doesn't provide any fatty acids
it's truly empty calories i know some
people talk about sugar as empty
calories but sugar actually is a far
better fuel source than alcohol or
acetate
but nonetheless
when you ingest alcohol some percentage
is being shuttled into a worse poison
and some is being shuttled into a fuel
source now the important thing to
understand is that it is the poison the
acetyl aldehyde itself that leads to the
effect of being inebriated or drunk
i think most people don't realize that
that being drunk is actually a poison
induced disruption in the way that your
neural circuits work and so we should
ask ourselves like which neural circuits
what brain areas what body areas
involved in feeling drunk or inebriated
now in thinking about this state of
being tipsy or happy or really drunk or
a little bit drunk
i want to mention something i think most
people aren't aware of
and that's the fact that for people that
are regular drinkers or that have a
genetic predisposition to alcoholism
when they drink they tend to feel very
energized and very good for longer
periods of time
again people have a genetic
predisposition to alcohol or people who
are chronic drinkers or even just
if you recall chronic doesn't have to
mean a ton of alcohol but they're
drinking one or two per night or they're
every other night type drinkers or
thursday through sunday drinkers
those people typically experience an
increase in alertness and mood when they
drink whereas occasional drinkers will
have a briefer
meaning less long-lasting period of
feeling good when they drink and then
more quickly transition into a state in
which they're tired or they start losing
motor skills they start slurring their
speech
i also want to emphasize this is
distinct from tolerance we'll talk about
tolerance later and exactly what
tolerance means but i really want to
highlight the fact that when people
ingest this poison because indeed it is
poison
the range of effects is very different
and you can
reliably predict who are the people with
a predisposition to alcoholism and who
are the people who are more regular
drinkers by the contour the timing of
the different effects and again
people who tend to feel more alert and
excited
every time they drink they tend to get a
real lift they'd be coming on the life
of the party and that lasts a long while
those people are the ones that really
have to be careful about
predisposition for alcoholism and those
people also need to be careful
about their drinking in the amount of
drinking that they're doing even if
they're not full-blown alcoholics
now of course people who are ingesting
alcohol who are not accustomed to drink
alcohol have to be concerned about
drinking alcohol for other reasons
because it can impair motor function and
judgment etc but
in thinking about the biochemical
effects of alcohol and what it's doing
to the body
what it's doing in all cases is
it's consumed into the gut right goes
into the stomach the liver immediately
starts this conversion that we talked
about before of ethanol to
acetylaldehyde to acetate and some
amount of acetyl aldehyde and acetate
are making it into the brain it crosses
the blood-brain barrier again the brain
has this fence around it that we call
the blood-brain barrier or the bbb
many things
most things thankfully can't pass across
the blood-brain barrier but alcohol
because it's water and fat soluble just
cruises right across this fence and into
the milieu the environment of the brain
which is made up of a couple different
major cell types neurons nerve cells and
so-called glial cells which are in
between the nerve cells and we'll talk
about the effects on each of those soon
so what happens when alcohol gets into
the brain that makes us feel tipsy or
drunk and in some people makes people
feel really
especially energized and happy well
alcohol is indiscriminate in terms of
which brain areas it goes to again it
doesn't bind to particular receptors but
it does seem to have a propensity or an
affinity for particular brain areas that
are involved in certain kinds of
thinking and behavior so one of the
first things that happens is that
there's a slight at least
after the first drink or second drink
there's a slight suppression in the
activity of neurons in the prefrontal
cortex this is an area of your neocortex
that's involved in thinking and planning
and perhaps above all in suppression of
impulsive behavior
so if you go to a party and they're
serving alcohol and people are consuming
drinks what you'll notice is that
a few minutes into that party the volume
of people's voices will increase and
that's because people are simply not
paying attention to their voice
modulation as other people start
speaking more loudly other people are
speaking more loudly we've all had this
experience right of going to a party and
then you step outside for a moment you
go oh my goodness i was shouting you
come over the next day you've got a sore
throat it might be that you picked up
some sort of bug some virus or something
but
oftentimes it's just the fact you've
been shouting all night just to be heard
because as the prefrontal cortex shuts
down people stop modulating their their
level of speech quite as much
also notice that people start
gesticulating more people start standing
up and sitting down more they'll start
walking around more if there's music on
people might spontaneously start dancing
all of this is because
these areas of the prefrontal cortex
normally are providing what's called
top-down inhibition they're releasing a
neurotransmitter called gaba
onto various parts of the brain they're
involved in impulsive motor behavior and
thought patterns and as you shut down
the prefrontal cortex that gabaergic
suppression
of impulses starts to be released so
people will say things that they want to
say without so much forethought about
what they're saying or they might do
things that they want to do without
really thinking it through quite as much
or they might not even remember thinking
it through at all or experience i should
say thinking it through it all we
haven't talked about blacking out yet in
the effects of alcohol on memory but as
long as we're there i'll just tell you
that alcohol has a very strong effect in
suppressing the neural networks that are
involved in memory formation and storage
this is why oftentimes we forget the
events of a night out
if we've been drinking
one of the more important things to know
about the effects of alcohol in the
brain
is this disruption in top-down
inhibition but also
that areas of the brain that are
involved in flexible behavior sort of
considering different options like i
could do a or i could do b i could say
this to that market say that i could say
it in that way or i could say it in this
way this might be a little more tactful
those brain areas basically shut down
entirely and people just tend to say
what they want to say so the key thing
to understand is that when people drink
the prefrontal cortex and top-down
inhibition
is diminished that is habitual behavior
and impulsive behavior starts to
increase now what's interesting is this
is true in the short term so after
people have one or two maybe three or
four drinks but it's also true that the
more often that people drink
there are changes in the very circuits
that underlie habitual and impulsive
behavior okay this is really important
to highlight so much so that i want to
drill into it a little bit more deeply
for the person that drinks say every
thursday night or every friday night or
goes out only on saturdays but every
saturday
there's evidence that there are changes
in the neural circuits of the brain that
control habitual behavior and impulsive
behavior
and they are modified and strengthened
in ways that make those people more
habitual and more impulsive
outside the times in which they are
drinking
and when they drink impulsive and
habitual behavior tends to increase even
further this is something that's not
often talked about when discussing the
effects of alcohol and we all know the
effects of being drunk can be bad right
can be bad in terms of judgment motor
coordination certainly driving drunk is
a terrible thing get you or other people
killed
and so on but rarely do we hear about
the changes in neural circuits from
just one or two nights of
regular drinking
again chronic drinking doesn't
necessarily mean every day and every
night it could be the person that simply
drinks every thursday or every friday or
just once a week has three or four
drinks or maybe even a few more
that person is going to experience a
decrease in this top down inhibition
so an increase in impulsivity and
habitual behavior because the break on
those behaviors has been removed while
they're drinking but also changes in the
very neural circuits that allow habitual
and impulsive behavior to occur more
readily even when they're not drinking
and if you want to know the actual
substrate for that the cellular
substrate i can briefly describe it it's
really interesting again you don't need
to know any biology to understand this
what it does is it increases the number
of synapses the actual points of
connection in the neural circuits that
control habitual behavior so there's
literally a growth of the neural
circuits in your brain that
lead to existing habit execution right
the performance of things you already
know how to do and a reduction in the
neural circuits or i should say a
reduction in the number of synapses of
the contacts within the neural circuits
that are controlling behavior so this
again is a not often discussed aspect of
alcohol intake fortunately it is
reversible so in animals or humans that
undertake a period of abstinence of
anywhere from two to six months these
neural circuits were returned to normal
except in cases where people have been
chronically drinking large volumes of
alcohol for many many years and in those
cases while there is some recovery of
brain circuitry
after
people get sober meaning completely
sober they stop drinking entirely
there is evidence of long-lasting impact
of heavy alcohol usage throughout the
lifespan but of course this doesn't mean
that anyone that's suffering from
alcoholism or they used to should not
continue to focus on their health you
absolutely should all is not lost but
for people that have been drinking for a
lot of years maybe you went to college
and you drank a lot in those years and
your neural circuits change if there's a
period in which you don't drink alcohol
again from two to six months and ideally
longer those neural circuits can then be
re-modified back to their original state
so let's consider some of the other
neurochemical effects of alcohol in the
brain and body and again for right now
we're confining the conversation
to people that are drinking on average
one or two drinks per night now some
people might think that two drinks per
night is a lot and a lot of that will
depend on body weight so for instance
people
who weigh 110 pounds
for them to ingest two alcoholic drinks
is going to be substantially different
in terms of the biochemical effects than
somebody who weighs 220 pounds
of course tolerance will also factor
into this genetic background will also
factor into this and indeed
whether or not people have eaten will
factor into this so there are a lot of
factors and we'll talk about that for
the time being if you're curious about
how food impacts
the effects of alcohol and your feelings
of being drunk you may have heard for
instance that if somebody's inebriated
and they want to sober up they should
eat something turns out that does not
work here's how it does work however
if you eat something prior to drinking
alcohol or while ingesting alcohol it
will slow the absorption of alcohol into
the bloodstream
in other words you won't feel as drunk
as fast for many of you this probably
comes as no surprise in particular if
that meal includes carbohydrates fats
and proteins okay the
inclusion of all three major
macronutrients seems to slow the
absorption of alcohol into the
bloodstream far more than any than
having any one of those or two of those
macronutrients present
now if you are already inebriated or
you've had a glass of wine or a beer and
you
eat something
chances are that alcohol has already
made it into your bloodstream because
it moves into the bloodstream so quickly
again it's fat soluble and water soluble
so within minutes if you're on if you
have an empty stomach within five to ten
minutes that alcohol is going to be
within your bloodstream and distributed
throughout your body maybe even faster
depending on the type of alcohol and
your metabolism
but
if you're already drunk and you eat
something it's not going to sober you up
more quickly but it certainly will blunt
the effects of any additional alcohol
that you might consume
and if you're somebody who is concerned
about getting too drunk too quick even
from a small amount of alcohol having
some food in your gut can certainly be
beneficial
now that's food and alcohol and the
absorption of alcohol but let's go back
to talking about the biochemical and
neurochemical effects of alcohol in the
brain we talked about top-down
inhibition and we talked about habitual
and impulsive behavior circuitry
there are also dramatic changes in the
activity of neurons that control the
release of so-called serotonin serotonin
is a neuromodulator it changes the
activity of neural circuits and many
neural circuits in particular those
involved in mood and feelings of
well-being recently there's been a lot
of interest in serotonin because of a
study that was released that showed
pretty conclusively that serotonin
levels can't really explain depression
and depression-like symptoms i want to
make it very clear that although that
study
did show that serotonin levels are not
necessarily associated with depression
the study was interpreted by many to
mean that ssri selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors which
have the net effect of increasing
serotonin so these are things like
prozac etc
that
those drugs are somehow not helpful
because
they increase serotonin and serotonin
isn't involved in depression
that logic doesn't really hold together
so i'm going to use this as an
opportunity to just clarify what really
occurred there and then we'll talk about
how serotonin relates to alcohol
consumption in things like feeling good
and in depression
the key thing is this
ssris can help alleviate depression
that's right ssris can help alleviate
depression they are often not always
associated with side effects dosage is
very important etc
but
they probably
support relief from depression
by changing neural circuits not
necessarily
by increasing serotonin itself that is
increasing serotonin with these drugs
likely change the neural circuits
involved in mood
allowing people to feel better through
so-called neuroplasticity which is the
brain's ability to change itself in
response to experience so there's a bit
of confusion and again i'm using this
episode on on alcohol to highlight some
of the confusion because i think it's
timely because the study just came out
and there's a lot of chatter about this
out there that when people are depressed
it's not necessarily because serotonin
levels are low however if serotonin
levels are increased with things like
prozac zoloft and other ssris
oftentimes there is yes a relief from
depression but that's probably not
because of restoring serotonin levels
per se it's probably because serotonin
facilitates
the changes in neural circuits that need
to occur in order for people to feel
elevated mood okay so again that's a bit
of a tangent and a side but i do think
it's a vital one for people to know
about
again if you're thinking about taking
ssris you're currently taking them and
you've heard this news definitely talk
to your doctor again there is great
utility for some of these ssris and also
in conditions like ocd they've been
shown to be very beneficial so we really
don't want to throw ssris out as a
potentially valuable treatment
getting back to the effects of alcohol
on serotonin it's very clear
beyond any doubt that many of the
circuits in the brain that are involved
in mood and feelings of well-being and
also
sort of self-image in how we see
ourselves employ the neuromodulator
serotonin and alcohol when we ingest it
and it's converted into acetyl aldehyde
it goes and that acetyl aldehyde acts as
a toxin at the very synapses the
connections between the serotonergic
neurons and lots of other neurons in
other words when we ingest alcohol the
toxic effects of alcohol disrupt those
mood circuitries at first making them
hyperactive that's right making them
hyperactive this is why people become
really talkative people start to feel
really good after a few sips of alcohol
at least most people do
and
then as they congest more alcohol or as
that alcohol wears off serotonin levels
and the activity of those circuits
really starts to drop and that's why
people feel less good and typically what
they do they go and get another drink
and they attempt to kind of restore that
feeling of well-being and mood now
typically what happens is that as people
ingest the third and fourth maybe even
the fifth drink
there's an absolute zero chance of them
recovering that energized mood right
most people as they drink more and more
will now start to feel more and more
suppressed the forebrain is now shutting
down quite a lot a lot of the motor
cortical areas that control coordinated
movement and deliberate movements start
to shut down so people start to slur
their speech people start to shuffle
their feet people forget their posture
people start to lean on things people
start passing out on couches there's a
great depression not depression of the
psychiatric depression sort but a
depression
of
alertness and arousal and eventually
people will pass out
now i said most people because there's a
subset of people that have gene variants
or who are
chronic drinkers or who are chronic
drinkers and have gene variants
that as they ingest the third and fourth
and fifth drink what happens they become
more alert they start talking more they
feel great they have all sorts of ideas
about the fun they could have that night
and they're the ones that if you've ever
fallen asleep at a party for whatever
reason or you're getting tired and
you're yawning you're looking around the
room and like these people are still
drinking and partying and they're having
what seems to be this amazing time
often not always
those are
the future alcoholics in the room or
those are the people
that have a genetic predisposition for
alcoholism or those are the chronic
drinkers the people who have built up
enough of a tolerance
or who have the chemical genetic makeup
such that increasing amounts of alcohol
make them feel better and better and
better and of course they too have a
threshold beyond which their nervous
system will start to get diminished and
they'll pass out and fall over et cetera
but that threshold is way way higher
than it is for most people
this is
important to understand and it's
important to understand because i think
everyone should know and recognize their
own predisposition and kind of risk
in terms of developing alcoholism it's
also important to understand because it
relates to the phenomenon of blackout
you know many people think that blacking
out is passing out but blackout drunk is
when people drink and they're talking
and doing things sometimes sadly they'll
or tragically they'll often drive home
or walk home or they'll hop on a bicycle
and ride home and they'll go swimming in
the ocean all of course very dangerous
activities
to do when people are really drunk or
even a little bit drunk in some cases so
these people will do these sorts of
things
and they do them because they have the
energy to do them and they feel good
while doing them
but they are doing them while the
activity of neurons in the hippocampus
which is involved in memory formation
are completely shut off and this is why
the next day
you tell them hey maybe we should talk
about what happened last night like what
happened last night he said well do you
remember going the party yeah it was
great we did this we did this and then
what and it's very clear all of a sudden
that they have no recollection of all
the things they were doing despite being
awake
now i wish i could tell you that there's
some sort of blood test or other
biomarker even a fingerprint test that
would allow you to determine whether or
not you have a propensity
to be one of these drinkers that has a
predisposition for alcoholism and if
you've ever been blackout drunk and
certainly if you've been blackout drunk
more than a few times you should be
quite concerned and as we talk more
about the more chronic effects and
long-lasting effects of alcohol
consumption a little bit later in the
episode
i think it will become clear as to why
you should be concerned
but
in any case
there is something that can tell you
whether or not you might be in that
category versus likely not in that
category and i alluded to this a couple
of times already but i want to be really
clear
that
when people drink no matter who you are
initially there's that shutting down of
those prefrontal cortical circuits
there's a gradual shutting down of the
circuits that control memory but then
people divide into these two bins and
these two bins are the people who after
more than a couple of drinks start to
feel sedated
and the people who after more than a few
drinks do not start to feel sedated
now of course there's going to be
differences created by how quickly
people are drinking whether or not
they're combining different types of
alcohol
the types of alcohol etc but in general
that can predict whether or not you're
somebody who has a predisposition for
alcoholism or not
one also very interesting finding is
that
alcohol changes the relationship between
what's called the hypothalamus and the
pituitary gland and the adrenals now the
hypothalamus is a small collection of
neurons about the size of a large
gumball sits above the roof of your
mouth and it houses neurons that are
responsible for some incredible aspects
of our behavior and our mindset things
like rage things like sex drive things
like temperature regulation very
primitive functions including appetite
thirst etc
alcohol because it can go anywhere in
the brain remember it's water and fat
soluble has effects on the hypothalamus
the hypothalamus
normally provides very specific signals
to what's called the pituitary gland
this is a little gland that actually
sticks out of the brain but it receives
instructions from the hypothalamus and
then the pituitary releases hormones
into the bloodstream that go and talk to
your adrenals your adrenal glands sit
right above your kidneys
in your lower back and the adrenals
release as the name suggests
adrenaline also called epinephrine and
also a molecule called cortisol
which is involved in the kind of longer
term stress response has some healthy
effects too on the immune system okay so
the hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis
i know that's a mouthful you don't need
to remember the names but the
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis
maintains your physiological balance of
what you perceive as stressful and what
you don't perceive as stressful
people who drink regularly so this again
could be just one or two drinks per
night or it could be somebody that
drinks just on fridays or just on
saturdays or maybe just on the weekend
two to four drinks well those people
experience changes in their hypothalamic
pituitary adrenal axis
that result in more cortisol more of
this so-called stress hormone being
released
at baseline when they are not drinking
this is really important
people who drink a bit and when i say a
bit i don't mean one or two sips or even
a glass of wine every once in a while i
mean again people that are maybe having
one drink a night with dinner and maybe
on the weekend a few more
can i offer a bunch of different
patterns to explain how it could also be
two or three drinks on friday or six
drinks only on saturday well all of
those groups experience increases in
cortisol release from their adrenal
glands
when they are not drinking and as a
consequence
they feel
more stressed and more anxiety when they
aren't drinking
this is a
seldom talked about effective alcohol
because so often we hear about the
immediate effects of alcohol and we've
been talking about some of those effects
effects like reducing the amount of
stress i mean how many times have we
heard somebody say uh i need a drink and
then they have a drink they're like calm
down now they can shake off the thoughts
about the day's work they can start to
think about things in a maybe more
grounded or rational way or at least
they believe that or they can somehow
just relax themselves well while that
very well may be true that it can relax
them when they are not drinking
that level of cortisol that's released
at baseline has increased substantially
again
this relates to a defined neural circuit
between brain and body and it has to do
with the ratio of cortisol to some of
the other hormones involved in the
stress response we'll provide a
reference to the study that describes
how all of this works for those of you
that really want to delve into it but
let's go back to this issue of those who
are prone to alcoholism versus those who
are not remember there are people who
have genetic variants that meaning genes
that they inherited from their parents
that make it more likely that they will
become alcoholics
but there are also people who drink
often who start to experience this
increase in alertness the longer they
drink across the night
part of that effect we think
is because of changes in this
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal axis so
alcohol is kind of a double hit in this
sense it's causing changes in our brain
circuitry and neurochemistry
that at the time in which were
inebriated are detrimental
and it's causing changes in neural
circuitry that persist long past the
time in which we're experiencing the
feeling of being tipsy or drunk
now again i don't want to demonize
alcohol i'm not saying oh you know if
you have a glass of wine now and again
or you drink a beer now and again or
even have um you know a mixed drink now
and again
or a shot that that's necessarily
terrible for you i certainly do not want
that to be the message
what i'm saying is that if people are
ingesting alcohol chronically even if
it's not every night there are
well recognized changes in neural
circuits
they're well recognized changes in
neurochemistry within the brain and
they're well recognized changes in the
brain to body stress system
that generally point in three directions
increase stress when people are not
drinking
diminished mood and feelings of
well-being when people are not drinking
and
as you'll soon learn changes in the
neural circuitry
that
cause people to want to drink even more
in order to get just back to baseline or
the place that they were in terms of
their stress modulation and in terms of
their feelings of mood before they ever
started drinking in the first place so
again i don't want to demonize alcohol
but i do want to emphasize that there
are long-term plastic changes meaning
changes in neural circuitry and hormone
circuitry that
across a period of several months and
certainly across a period of years of
the sorts of drinking patterns i
described which i think
for most people are going to sound like
pretty typical right i mean nothing that
i described so far was about drinking a
case a night or or about binging on
alcohol and the ways that we often hear
about it in the news these are pretty
common patterns of alcohol consumption i
mean all you have to do is board a
transatlantic flight or actually go to
an airport on a sunday afternoon in a
sunny area of the u.s and you know
people are having three four five six
beers etc
again personal choice is personal choice
i'm not telling you what to do but it's
very clear that those sorts of drinking
patterns are changing neural circuitry
and they're changing hormone circuitry
and i'd love to be able to tell you that
they're changing them for the better but
they
simply are not they're actually changing
them for the worse and worse is defined
as making people less resilient to
stress higher levels of baseline stress
and lower mood overall
before we continue with today's
discussion i'd like to just briefly
acknowledge our sponsor athletic greens
now called ag-1
athletic greens akag-1 is an all-in-one
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that
also has adaptogens and digestive
enzymes i've been taking athletic greens
since way back in 2012 so i'm delighted
that they're sponsoring the podcast the
reason i started taking athletic greens
and the reason i still drink athletic
greens twice a day is that it supplies
total foundational coverage of my
vitamin mineral needs and it supplies
important nutrients that i need to
support my gut microbiome the gut
microbiome as many of you know supports
the immune system it also supports the
so-called gut brain axis which is vital
for mood for energy levels for
regulating focus and many other features
of our mental health and physical health
that impact our daily performance and
high performance in any endeavors we
might be involved in if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com
huberman and claim a special offer
they're giving away five free travel
packs plus a year's supply of vitamin d3
k2 with every order and of course
vitamin d3 k2 are vital for all sorts of
things like hormone health and metabolic
health and k2 for cardiovascular health
and calcium regulation again you can go
to athletic greens.com huberman to claim
that special offer now i've been talking
a little bit about genetic
predisposition
but there are a couple of important
points i'd like to make about that first
of all what sorts of genes are involved
in
setting someone down the path of
alcoholism or not well it should come as
no surprise that the genes that chronic
alcohol usage
modifies they tend to fall primarily in
the pathways related to
genetic control over serotonin receptors
gaba receptors remember that top-down
inhibition and the involvement of gaba
and
no surprise the hpa the hypothalamic
pituitary axis all of those of course
combine with environment they combine
with patterns of abuse right we know
that if you're in a social setting where
a lot of people are drinking the
likelihood that you're going to drink is
much higher
social pressures
trauma right some people will use
alcohol to self-medicate to try and turn
off their thinking or to deal with
trauma etc so they combine with the
environment but the genes that are in
the serotonin synthesis and
receptor synthesis pathway gaba and hpa
axis combine with environmental
pressures
to give rise to
alcohol use disorders
so there's a fairly coherent picture
that we have here right this is not a
case where for instance people that have
a lot of the enzyme for metabolizing
alcohol which we'll talk about in a
minute alcohol dehydrogenase
it's not like they are necessarily the
people that become alcoholics whereas
certainly in certain cultures certain
asian cultures in particular
there are gene differences that lead
them to have low levels of alcohol
dehydrogenase they're actually people
who have so little alcohol dehydrogenase
that when they ingest alcohol they get
very red and they just feel sick so if
you're somebody has a sip of alcohol and
you just feel horrible it makes you feel
nauseous chances are you have
gene variants that create a situation
where you're not making very much
alcohol dehydrogenase you just simply
can't metabolize alcohol so you just get
a rapid build up of the toxic effects of
alcohol the acetyl aldehyde you're not
converting it into those empty calories
but in cultures where you have a lot of
genetic variants and genes expressed in
people where they have a lot of alcohol
dehydrogenase sure they can drink more
and they're converting more of that
alcohol from its toxic form to a
non-toxic form and yes of course you
will observe more alcoholism in those
communities because they're drinking
more but i do want to emphasize that the
environmental factors are playing a
strong role there too because if you can
drink more you're likely to drink more
if you're somebody that feels sick
immediately from drinking it's likely
that you're not going to engage in
alcohol consumption especially if these
things are genetically related and of
course genes and culture and location in
the world tend to run together
so
do you have the gene for alcoholism well
there isn't one single gene
chances are if you have an immediate
relative who's a chronic abuser of
alcohol or several
relatives who are chronic abusers of
alcohol well that's going to predispose
you to be an alcoholic
but since you don't know which genes you
express unless you do genetic testing
and those things are available but most
people aren't doing that
this
assay if you will it's not an assay as
we say an assay is a test that you run
in the lab
to determine something
and it's not one that i recommend that
you go drink in order to do but if
you've noticed that you or somebody else
is somebody who can drink a lot
throughout the night and have increased
energy you can just drink and drink a
drink
and especially if there's blackout
episodes not remembering things the next
day despite being alert throughout the
entire night and so on well then i would
be very concerned that you might
actually have a genetic variant
predisposing you to alcoholism the other
thing that predisposes people to abuse
of alcohol
is age people who start drinking at
younger ages
are greatly
predisposed to developing alcohol
dependence regardless of your family
history of alcoholism okay so i'm going
to repeat that people who start drinking
younger are at great risk for developing
alcoholism even if they don't have
alcoholism in their family now of course
you don't have to be an epidemiologist
to understand that if you grow up in a
family of drinkers and alcohol is
everywhere and especially if there's
peer pressure or lack of oversight then
there's going to be a higher tendency or
a higher probability i should say that
you will start drinking at a younger age
however even people that grow up nowhere
near their relatives if they start
drinking at a young age so for instance
at 13 or younger or 14 or 15 there's a
much higher probability that they're
going to develop a long lasting
dependence on alcohol
people who take their first sip of
alcohol later
15 16 or one would hope even later i can
say one would hope because i'm now that
you know age and generation where you
you know you think about all the things
that uh young people do and you go oh
gosh if they only would wait or if they
only would abstain you know so what
happens i don't know there's some neural
circuit for that that i can't explain
yet but people who for instance
drink only once they reach legal age of
drinking which in the u.s i believe in
every state is 21 years old
if they take their first drink at 21 the
probability that they'll go on to
develop full-blown alcohol dependence or
alcohol use disorder as it's called aud
is very low now a subset of them will
because they have such a strong genetic
predisposition or maybe life
circumstances create
a pattern in which they become a chronic
drinker but i found this very
interesting genes matter
but also the age in which somebody
starts drinking really matters now
whether or not that's because there are
changes in neural circuitry as a
consequence of that drinking that make
people want to seek out more and more
alcohol
or whether or not there's some other
effect maybe it's a change in hormones
etc that predisposes those young
drinkers to become chronic drinkers or
even full-blown alcoholics certainly
developing alcohol use disorder there's
definition for that we can talk about it
it involves the amount of drinking over
a certain period of time etc so it's
very clear that drinking early in life
creates a propensity for the development
of alcohol use disorder later in life
and while there is a genetic component
to developing alcohol use disorder
i find it very interesting that if
people who have those gene variants
delay their onset of drinking well then
the probability that they'll develop
full-blown alcohol use disorder drops as
well
so again it's genes and environments not
in either or and there's no single gene
for alcoholism well i promise you i will
also talk about some of the documented
positive effects of alcohol although
they are very few and far between they
do exist
but before i do that i would be remiss
if i didn't emphasize some more of the
terrible things that alcohol does and
the way that it does it
and for those of you that enjoy alcohol
i again i really
like to say i feel guilty about telling
you this because i know how much some
people enjoy a good drink every once in
a while and i say a good drink because
some people do like the taste of alcohol
i suppose i lucked out and that i don't
really like the taste of alcohol and
that just puts me to sleep but i know
that people do enjoy it and i do want to
point out that
there is zero evidence
that you know provided somebody is of
drinking age certainly not in the stage
of brain development that having one
drink or two drinks every now and again
meaning
every three or four weeks or once a
month that is not going to cause major
health concerns or major health issues
for most people
i suppose if you have zero or very
little alcohol dehydrogenase it might
make you feel sick but then you're not
probably not the kind of person that's
going to be drinking at all
so
again if you enjoy alcoholic drinks i'm
not trying to
take them away from you by any means
but you should know what drinking does
if you're consuming it in this kind of
typical chronic pattern as we can now
refer to it which is that one or two a
night or a few stacked up
on friday and maybe three or four on
saturday this kind of pattern of
drinking which is quite common and one
of the more serious effects that we
should think about is the impact on the
so-called gut brain access or for sake
of today's discussion the gut liver
brain axis i don't think the gut liver
brain access has ever been discussed on
this podcast maybe any podcast although
the moment i say that i'm gonna you know
the the gut liver brain axis
people are gonna come after me with i
suppose gut liver brain and brains in
any event
you have a brain
you have a gut
that gut runs from your throat down to
the end of your intestine
your gut and your brain communicate by
way of nerve cells neurons and nerve
connections the vagus nerve in
particular and by way of chemical
signaling
your gut also communicates by way of
chemical signaling and believe it or not
by way of neural signaling to to your
liver and as we talked about earlier the
liver is the first site in which alcohol
is broken down or metabolized into its
component parts
the liver is also communicating with the
brain through chemical signaling and
neural signaling so we have the gut
liver brain axis
and
what you find is that people who ingest
alcohol
at any amount
are inducing a disruption in the
so-called gut microbiome the
trillions of little microbacteria that
take resident in your gut and that live
inside you all the time and help support
your immune system and that literally
signal by way of electrical signals and
chemical signals to your brain to
increase the release of things like
serotonin and dopamine and regulate your
mood generally in positive ways well
alcohol really disrupts those bacteria
this should come as no surprise i mean
earlier we talked about this and it's
well known if you want to you know
sterilize something you might kill the
bacteria you pour alcohol on it i can
remember scraping my um
myself or cutting myself i was always
injuring myself when i was a kid and you
know the moment they take out the
peroxide you're like oh boy here it
comes but if there's no peroxide around
and you've got a wound there you need to
clean it out yeah they they'll use
alcohol which i do not recommend by the
way that's one of the harshest ways to
clean a wound but for centuries
thousands of years really alcohol has
been used in order to clean things and
kill bacteria
so
alcohol kills bacteria and it is
indiscriminate with respect to which
bacteria it kills so when we ingest
alcohol and it goes into our gut it
kills a lot of the healthy gut
microbiota
at the same time the metabolism of
alcohol in the liver which you now
understand that pathway involving nad
acetyl acetylaldehyde and acetate that
pathway
is pro-inflammatory so it's increasing
the release of inflammatory cytokines
things like il-6 etc tumor necrosis
factor alpha if you'd like to learn more
about the immune system we did an
episode all about the immune system you
can find at ubermanlab.com i'll teach
you all the basics of what are cytokines
what are mast cells etc in any event all
these pro-inflammatory molecules
those are being released
you've now got disruption of the gut
microbiota as a consequence the lining
of the gut is disrupted and you develop
at least transiently leaky gut that is
bacteria that exist in the gut which are
bad bacteria can now pass out of the gut
into the bloodstream so you've got a
two-hit kind of model here in biology we
talk about two-hit models that is kind
of a one plus one equals four and it's
generally when you hear two hit it's not
a good thing so you've got bad bacteria
from partially broken down food moving
out of the gut the good bacteria in the
gut have been killed you might say why
isn't the alcohol kill the bad bacteria
in the gut well the bad bacteria that
are from partially digested food
oftentimes escape the gut
before the alcohol can
disrupt them and so now you've got leaks
in the gut wall you've got the release
of this bad bacteria you've got
inflammatory cytokines and other things
being released from the liver and they
are able to get into the brain through
neuro what's called a neuroimmune
signaling
and what's really bizarre in terms of
the way that this manifests in the brain
i mean it's not the way i would have
done it but then again as i always say i
wasn't consulted at the design phase and
anyone who says they did you should be
very skeptical of them
the net effect of this is actually to
disrupt
the neural circuits that control
regulation of alcohol intake and
the net effect of that is increased
alcohol consumption so this is just
terrible right i mean to your take in
something that disrupts two systems the
gut microbiota and it disrupts in two
ways it's killing the good gut
microbiota and it's allowing the bad
bacteria to move from the gut into the
bloodstream you've also got
pro-inflammatory cytokines coming from
the liver and those
converge or arrive in the brain
and
create a system in which the neural
circuits cause more drinking
that's a bad situation and this is why
people who drink regularly even if it's
not a ton of alcohol
again of the sorts of patterns of
drinking i've talked about before and
certainly for those that are chronic
heavy drinkers
what you end up with is a situation in
which you have inflammation in multiple
places in the brain and body and the
desire to drink even more and to further
exacerbate that inflammation and the gut
leakyness so this is basically a
terrible scenario for the gut liver
brain axis and it's especially prevalent
in so-called alcohol use disorder again
people that are ingesting somewhere
between 12 and 24 drinks per week for
those of you that are interested in
learning more about the gut liver brain
axis and in particular alcohol use
disorder i'll provide a link in the show
note captions now there's a wonderful
review on this that details that
but on the positive side it points to
the possibility that at least some again
at least some of the negative effects of
alcohol consumption whether or not
you're somebody who's currently
ingesting alcohol or who used to ingest
alcohol and is trying to so-called
repair these systems of the brain and
body whether or not replenishing the gut
microbiota is going to be beneficial and
we know that there are ways to do that
and we know that there's at least some
promise for the ability for the system
to repair itself how does one do that
well i've talked before about this on
the podcast but studies done by
colleagues of mine at stanford justin
sonenberg who's been on this podcast as
a guest an amazing episode all about the
gut microbiome and his collaborator
chris garner also at stanford school of
medicine
have explored
not alcoholism but what are ways to
improve
the
gut microbiota in particular to reduce
the
production of inflammatory cytokines and
to adjust what's called the inflammatome
you've heard of the genome and the
proteome etc well the inflammatome is
the
total array or at least the near total
array of genes and proteins that control
inflammation how can you reduce
inflammation and make that inflammatome
healthier well they've shown that two to
four servings of fermented foods per day
and here i'm not referring to fermented
alcohol i'm talking about low sugar
fermented foods so things like kimchi
sauerkraut
natto for the for those of you that like
japanese food
there are others i know things like
kefir things like
yogurts that have a lot of active
bacteria again low sugar varieties of
all these things
those are terrific at
reducing inflammatory markers and at
improving the gut microbiome
one could imagine that either
inoculating oneself from some of the
effects of alcohol although i'd prefer
that people just not drink alcohol
chronically frankly or if somebody's
trying to repair their gut microbiome
because they ingested a lot of alcohol
or because they had a lot of these
inflammatory cytokines for many years or
even a short period of time
regular ingestion of two to four
servings of these fermented foods can be
quite beneficial
i want to make it clear that has not
been examined specifically in the
context of
alcohol use disorder but
because a huge component of the negative
effects of alcohol use disorder are
based in this gut liver brain access and
disruption of the gut microbiome and the
inflammatory cytokines it stands to
reason that things that are well
established to improve
inflammation status in other words
reduce inflammation such as ingesting
two to four servings of low sugar
fermented foods per day
makes sense in terms of trying to repair
or replenish the system
one could also imagine taking probiotics
or prebiotics certainly that would work
as well
although i've sort of favored the
discussion around fermented foods and
replenishment of the gut microbiome
mostly because there are more studies
that have examined that in humans and
because of the direct relationship
that's been established between doing
that and reducing negative markers
within the inflammatome and i should
mention along the lines of repair and
recovery i put out a question on twitter
the other day i said what do you want to
know about alcohol i got more than a
thousand questions and i'll take some
more of those questions a little later
in the episode but one of the things i
noticed is that many of the questions
hundreds in fact
related to
the question of well if i drank a lot
previously am i doomed can i reverse the
negative effects or um you know i'm
trying to drink less and i'm trying to
improve my health as i as i do that what
should i do well certainly um
focusing a bit on the gut microbiome
ought to be useful the other thing i
should mention is as people wean
themselves off alcohol even if they're
not full-blown alcoholics or have
alcohol use disorder they should
understand
that
that increase in cortisol that we talked
about earlier that leads to lower stress
threshold and greater feelings of
anxiety and stress
that's going to be present and it's
going to take some time to dissipate so
for some people it might even just be
helpful to realize that as you try and
wean yourself off alcohol or maybe even
go cold turkey that
increased anxiety and feelings of stress
should be expected and in that case i
would point you to an episode that we
did on master stress you can find that
again at hubermanlab.com it's got a ton
of behavioral nutritional
supplementation based exercise based i
suppose exercise this behavioral but a
lot of tools you can navigate to those
easily because we have time stamps you
can go right to the topic of interest
those tools are going to be very useful
in trying to clamp or control your
stress and the point here is just that
some increase in stress should be
expected
and it should be expected because of
that increase in cortisol that occurs
with even low level consumption yet
chronic alcohol consumption now i'd like
to talk about a fairly common phenomenon
which is
post-alcohol consumption malaise also
referred to as hangover
hangover is
a constellation of effects ranging from
headache to nausea to what sometimes
called anxiety which is anxiety that
follows a day of drinking
anxiety i think we can
understand physiologically if we think
about that process of
alcohol intake increasing the amount of
cortisol and the ratio of cortisol to
some other stress hormones
that well explains why some people wake
up the day after or even the day the day
after
a night drinking and feel anxious and
not well and stressed for reasons they
don't understand
so
if you're somebody who experiences
anxiety then again i refer you to the
master stress episode that we put out
some time ago and you can find that
hubermanlab.com tools to deal with
anxiety tools to deal with stress
ranging again from behavioral to
nutritional supplement based etc
that of course is not
justification for going out and drinking
so much that you get anxiety
induced hangover but for those of you
that are experiencing post alcohol
consumption anxiety
as it were
that could be a useful resource because
i certainly don't want anyone
experiencing
uncomfortable amounts of anxiety and
there are great tools and resources for
that now the other aspects of hangover
such as the stomach ache
or
headache or feelings of malaise or
fogginess those could be related to a
number of different things and probably
are related to a number of different
things first of all
the sleep that one gets after even just
one yes even just one
glass of wine or a beer is not the same
sleep that you get when you don't have
alcohol circulating in your system and
not trying to be a downer here but this
was discussed in the hubert lab podcast
episode
where i had
dr matthew walker from uc berkeley on
and of course dr walker is a world
expert in sleep runs one of the
preeminent laboratories studying sleep
and its effects
wrote the incredible book why we sleep
and so on
dr walker told me and it certainly is
supported by
lots and lots of quality peer-reviewed
studies in animals and in humans that
when alcohol is present in the brain and
bloodstream that the architecture of
sleep is disrupted slow wave sleep deep
sleep and rapid eye movement sleep all
of which are essential for getting a
restorative night's sleep are all
disrupted so for those of you that are
drinking a glass or two of wine or
having a
hard
liquor drink or a beer in order to fall
asleep the sleep you're getting is
simply not high quality sleep or
certainly not as high quality as the
sleep you'd be getting if you did not
have alcohol in your system
of course when we're talking about
hangover we're talking generally about
the consumption of more than just one or
two drinks
of course for some people one or two
drinks is probably sufficient to induce
hangover but for most people it's going
to be having three or four exceeding
their typical limit as it's called again
not the legal limit that's a whole other
business
but when one ingests
too much alcohol for them
one of the reasons they feel
terrible the next day is because their
sleep isn't really good sleep in fact
it's not even sleep it's often
considered pseudo sleeper at least
that's what it's called in the sleep
science field because people are in kind
of a low level hypnotic kind of trance
it's not real sleep there are multiple
ballots of waking up they may not even
realize they're waking up multiple times
okay so there's the sleep induced
effects then there are the disrupted gut
microbiome effects some of which we
talked about earlier so now you
understand the mechanism of alcohol
destroying
good healthy gut microbiota which then
leads to leaky gut and things of that
sort but one could imagine again could
imagine and there is some evidence
starting to support this that again
ingesting low sugar fermented foods or
maybe in prebiotic or probiotics to
support the gut microbiome might assist
in some of the
gut related malaise associated with
hangover in other words get those gut
microbiota healthy again as quickly as
possible or maybe even before you drink
have those got microbiota healthy i
would hope that you do that i think
everybody should be doing something to
support their gut microbiome whether or
not it's the ingestion of low sugar
fermented foods daily or at least on a
regular basis or ingestion of probiotic
or prebiotic the gut microbiome is so
important for so many different things
in terms of hangover
and headache we know that that's caused
by vasoconstriction the constriction of
blood vessels that tends to occur as a
rebound after a night of drinking
alcohol can act as a vasodilator it can
dilate the blood vessels part of that is
associated with the increase in
so-called parasympathetic tone we have
an autonomic nervous system it's got a
sympathetic component these are neurons
that make us more alert and if they're
very active they make us very stressed
there's also the parasympathetic
aspect of the autonomic nervous system
this is all just fancy geek speak for
the parts of your brain and body the
nerve cells that make you very relaxed
when you're very relaxed there tends to
be
vasodilation it allows for more movement
of blood and other things through the
bloodstream
and alcohol tends to induce some
vasodilation at least in some of the
capillary beds and then when the alcohol
wears off there's a vasoconstriction and
people get brutal headaches that's why
some people will take aspirin or tylenol
or
advil or things like that they're sort
of non-steroid anti-inflammatories i
should mention there's a lot of
literature coming out that some of these
non-steroid anti-inflammatory drugs are
not good for us for a number of
different reasons the way they impact
the liver the way they impact the immune
system and no surprise the way they
impact the gut microbiome so i'm not one
to tell you what medications to take or
not take but you certainly would want to
do a quick web search of effects of
non-steroid
anti-inflammatories
and aspirin before you start taking
those or stop taking those for that
matter
generally they will alleviate headache
but they can often have other issues
including liver issues and keep in mind
the night after drinking your liver has
already taken a beating because of the
need of the liver to convert
alcohol from acetylaldehyde into acetate
which is now a pathway that you well
understand so i'm not
certain and in fact i believe it's not
the greatest idea to burden your liver
further through the use of things
that are going to cause it to have to
work harder and metabolize things if the
goal is simply to alleviate a headache
there's a lot of kind of lore
old school lore about how to relieve a
hangover we already talked about how
eating food won't do that but eating
food will prevent
the rapid absorption of even more
alcohol into the bloodstream
there's the lore that one should simply
ingest more alcohol what terrible advice
that is that's just going to delay an
even worse hangover however
i'd be remiss if i didn't say that the
reason that that
myth came to be or that i should say
that truth came to be
because indeed ingesting more alcohol
will alleviate a hangover but then a
worse hangover will show up the reason
that came to be is because ingestion
more alcohol will cause
those constricted vessels that are
giving the headache to dilate again
but of course ingesting more alcohol to
relieve a hangover is simply a bad idea
just don't do it i think this is called
the hair of the dog approach maybe
someone can put in the show note
captions on youtube why it's called the
hair of the dog
i can come up with a few ideas but um
they're not going to be very good ones
and some of them would probably even be
outright ridiculous so do not ingest
more alcohol simply to try and recover
from a hangover i know many people have
tried that one before but that's a
terrible idea now one thing that you'll
also hear out there is that deliberate
cold exposure for instance taking a cold
shower might relieve hangover i find
this one particularly interesting
because we've done episodes on the
benefits of deliberate cold exposure we
have an entire episode about that you
can find it again hubermanlab.com
there are direct links to some of the
tools related to deliberate cold
exposure and we have an entire
newsletter on deliberate cold exposure
protocols you can find on
hubermanlab.com go to our neural network
newsletter so these those of you that
are interested in ice baths and cold
showers and ways to leverage those
you can find that there what you won't
find there is a description of how to
use deliberate cold exposure for sake of
treating hangover but here i went into
the literature and i found something
kind of interesting there is some
evidence that increasing levels of
epinephrine in the bloodstream can
actually help with alcohol clearance
that was very surprising to me and i
want to point out this is not a large
and robust literature but there's some
evidence pointing to the fact that when
levels of epinephrine adrenaline are
raised in the brain and bloodstream that
some of the components of alcohol
metabolism can be accelerated and some
of the
inebriating effects of alcohol can be
reduced so maybe this old-school lore of
taking a cold shower actually has
something to it so in thinking about the
use of deliberate cold exposure in order
to reduce the effects of hangover or to
more rapidly clear
alcohol from the brain and bloodstream i
want to be very clear and i want to
emphasize your safety
the way to do that is to understand that
alcohol lowers core body temperature
okay it can make people slightly
hypothermic it's going to drop core body
temperature
so if you were inebriated and you went
and got into a body of water right a
pool or a lake or something first of all
that's extremely dangerous to do while
you're inebriated right people drown all
the time people drown they die as a
consequence of doing that so please
don't do that but also it's very cold
water your core body temperature is
going to drop even further now if you've
heard the episodes that i've done on
deliberate cold exposure
previously i've talked about how
normally when people are
not ingesting alcohol they get into an
ice bath or a cold shower and their body
temperature initially dips but then it
rebounds and increases that's a process
that's going to occur when people do not
have alcohol in their system
when you have alcohol in your system one
of the reasons that you become
hypothermic
is because there's a disruption in those
hypothalamic brain areas in particular
the brain area called the medial
pre-optic area that regulates core body
temperature so it's not so much that
alcohol makes you cold it's that alcohol
disrupts the central command centers of
the brain that control temperature
regulation and that leads you to be
slightly hypothermic so if you then go
get into a very cold lake or you get
into
even a cold shower or an ice bath
there's the possibility of you going
very very far down the ladder into
very hypothermic territory and that can
be very dangerous now in terms of
dealing with hangover when the alcohol
has been largely cleared from your
system well that's where some of this
kind of old lore combines with some of
the modern science and says well if you
can spike adrenaline
and certainly getting into an ice bath
or getting into a cold shower or any
kind of cold body of water provided you
can do that safely that will sharply
increase your adrenaline and i should
say your dopamine that's been shown and
we've talked about this on the podcast
before you get these long
extended increases several hours of
increases in dopamine from deliberate
cold exposure it's well documented in
humans by the way
so one could imagine
using deliberate cold exposure as a way
to accelerate the recovery from hangover
provided that's done safely i think
there's no reason to not explore that
and if you wonder what safely is and
what temperatures to use please check
out the episode on deliberate cold
exposure
cold showers therefore might actually be
one way to at least partially relieve
hangover certainly the science from
various
places in the literature converge to say
that but again be careful please please
please be careful not to get into cold
water when you are inebriated it's
absolutely dangerous for all the obvious
reasons and it's dangerous also for the
non-obvious reasons not the least of
which is the dramatic decreases in core
body temperature that can make you
dangerously hypothermic now how would
you go about using deliberate cold
exposure to accelerate recovery from
hangover well there i would look to the
kind of standard protocols of you know
one to three minutes or maybe even six
minutes if you can tolerate or if you're
really cold adapted
maybe you do seven or ten minutes in a
cold shower although that could be a lot
most people are going to experience a
sharp increase in epinephrine and
adrenaline and a long-lasting increase
in dopamine from one to three minutes of
deliberate cold exposure ideally done
immersion up to the neck again do this
safely please please please or a cold
shower where you're getting under the
shower as much as possible how cold well
that's going to vary person to person i
suggest making it as cold as is
uncomfortable such that you really want
to get out but you know you can stay in
safely without for instance giving
yourself a heart attack because if the
water is really really cold of course
you can give yourself a heart attack
most showers won't go that cold although
probably some will
again please use caution spike your
adrenaline spike your dopamine with
deliberate cold exposure safely other
components of hangover that could be
good targets for trying to alleviate
hangover and here i hope you are getting
the picture because it is accurate to
say
that hangover is a multi-faceted
phenomenon it's not like one molecule in
one receptor it's a bunch of things
happening in the brain and body
but is the dehydration associated with
alcohol alcohol is a diuretic for
multiple reasons it causes people to
excrete
not only water but also sodium sodium is
an electrolyte critical for the function
of neurons so making sure that you have
enough sodium potassium and magnesium
so-called electrolytes is going to be
important
for
proper brain function bodily organ
function
even for people that have just had one
or two drinks the night before it's
likely that your electrolyte balance and
your fluid balance is going to be
disrupted and that's because alcohol
also disrupts the so-called vasopressin
pathway i talked a lot about vasopressin
and the way that
it interacts with and controls different
aspects of water retention and water
released from the body in the form of
urine in the episode on salt so you
again i'm
referring to hubermanlab.com as the site
where you can find that episode on salt
balance and ways to restore electrolyte
balance having your electrolytes
at the proper levels before you drink is
ideal some people will say for every
glass of alcohol that you drink you
should drink one glass of water i would
say
better would be two glasses of water
given the dehydrating effects of alcohol
and even better would be water with
electrolytes that certainly would set
you up for a better day the next day
and if you don't manage to do that
because i suppose it's kind of geeky
walking around with electrolyte packets
out at the bar
or whatnot although you know um in geeky
my book is a good thing
the next day you could take some
electrolytes upon waking
maybe even some before you go to sleep
at the night of drinking so hangovers
made worse by disturbed sleep made worse
by disruptive gut microbiome made worse
by disrupted electrolytes made worse by
the depletion of epinephrine and
dopamine that's why replenishing the
microbiome with fermented foods low
sugar fermented foods that is that's why
using safe deliberate cold exposure for
spiking adrenaline and for increasing
dopamine
and that's why consuming electrolytes
are all going to be beneficial
the folks over at examine.com a website
that i really like
because it just has so much useful
information
have assembled a list of things that
have been
proposed purported to improve or i
should say to remove the effects of
hangover and as they point out and i
would like to point out over there there
isn't a lot of quality science to
support the idea that any one compound
can eliminate hangover and that's
probably because hangover again arises
from multiple organs and tissues and
systems in both the brain and body
nonetheless they have a terrific um list
over there of things everything from
japanese pear fruit juice has been
proposed to do this to
some other really esoteric things even
things like yohimbine
frankly when i look at the literature
there and elsewhere
one simply cannot find the magic
substance the one herb the one potion
that can wipe away hangover
getting rid of hangover is going to be
best solved by doing a collection of a
small number of very powerful things
which i've already listed off a few
however there are some additional things
that one can do
for relieving hangover and one of them
is to be
very thoughtful about what sorts of
alcohol one consumes so i find this
interesting
there have actually been studies of
which types of alcohol lead to the
greatest hangovers there's actually a
lot of legend and lore about this
uh as well some people have said for
instance that drinks that have a high
sugar content lead to greater hangovers
turns out that's not the case at least
that's not what the science points to if
you look at the expected hangover
severity what you find is that at the
bottom end of the scale there's a drink
that i'm not going to tell you
for the moment
but what you find is that near it is for
instance beer the
the consumption of beer provided it is
not over consumption right it's not far
beyond the tolerance of the individual
it says one or two beers is less likely
to cause a hangover than say whiskey
and a glass of whiskey or i should you
know not as much whiskey as beer of
course but a glass of whiskey for
instance is
more likely to cause hangover than gin
is it turns out again this is
what's falling out of the data and yet
a glass of rum or red wine is more
likely to cause a hangover than any of
the other things i've mentioned so far
at the top top top of the list of drinks
that induce hangover is brandy
and one could then say well doesn't
brandy have a lot of sugar maybe it's
the sugar that's causing hangovers and
this is something that's been again
discussed over and over that people say
oh it's the high sugar drinks that cause
hangover it turns out however
that when one looks at drinks alcoholic
drinks and sugar content and hangover at
the very bottom of the list is
gosh this makes me cringe just to think
about is ethanol diluted in orange juice
ugh i can't believe people actually
drink this but ethanol diluted in orange
juice so this is not vodka and orange
juice okay vodka was third on the list
from the bottom of drinks that induce
hangover again this is within amounts
that are
comfortable for the person to drink that
they have enough experience with or that
they have the body weight to tolerate
without getting very very drunk
so
the point is that if it were sugar
that's causing hangover well then the
ethanol dilute in orange juice would
probably be at the top of the list into
in terms of inducing hangover but it's
not it's at the bottom of the list and
brandy is at the top of the list so what
you find is that what scales from
ethanol diluting orange juice to beer to
vodka to gin here i'm ascending the
hierarchy of things that cause hangover
gin white wine whiskey rum red wine and
then brandy at the peak it's sort of the
world heavyweight champion of hangover
inducing drinks
well what's increasing are congeners
within those drinks congeners are things
like nitrites and other substances that
give alcohol its
distinctive flavor and that also lead to
some of the
inebriating effects of alcohol now then
you ask okay well what is it that these
congeners are doing and what are these
nitrites doing and guess what
while they do have effects on the brain
and on other tissues
their main effects are to disrupt the
gut microbiome
so
what this points to again is that having
a healthy gut microbiome and perhaps
ensuring that you bolster
your gut microbiome
the day after drinking is going to be
especially important for
warding off hangover or at least
reducing the effects
of hangover or the symptoms of hangover
or both i would love to see a study on
this
i could imagine designing the study
myself although this isn't really the
sort of things my laboratory does
but you can imagine some people getting
probiotic and prebiotic some
regularly some just after drinking or
low sugar fermented foods
and see what the effects are in terms of
subjective effects of hangover but also
some physiological measures
i think the way to think about hangover
overall is that again it represents a
multi-faceted
multi-organ multi-tissue
phenomenon and the best way to deal with
it is as a multi-cell multi-tissue
multi-chemical phenomenon and before i
listed off some of the things that one
could do in order to adjust hangover
again
the one that comes out at the top of
that list i believe at least based on my
read of the data is to support the gut
microbiome
and certainly not to ingest more alcohol
and i suppose if we were to get really
honest with one another
and ask what's the best way to avoid a
hangover it would be to not drink in the
first place so we've covered the major
effects of alcohol that lead to this
state that we call
drunkenness or inebriation
again there's a range there you can be
tipsy people can be blackout drunk
people can be passed out drunk we've
also talked about hangover and the fact
that it's a multifaceted phenomenon and
recovery from hangover involves a
multi-faceted approach
next i want to talk about tolerance
tolerance to alcohol is a very
interesting phenomenon it has roots
mainly in the brain and in brain systems
there's not time in the world let alone
within this podcast to get into all the
aspects of tolerance there are more than
10 different types of tolerance there's
functional tolerance chronic tolerance
rapid tolerance there's metabolic
tolerance there's psychological
tolerance
let's keep it simple for sake of today's
discussion and for those of you that are
interested in learning about all the
different types of tolerance and aspects
of tolerance there's an excellent review
we will provide a link to this this was
published in 2021 so it's pretty recent
in the journal pharmacology biochemistry
and behavior
incidentally or not someone's only that
was the first journal i ever published
in so i have a particular affection for
that journal nonetheless it is called
tolerance to alcohol a critical yet
understudied factor in alcohol addiction
and while this
paper does include alcohol addiction in
the title it's not just about alcohol
addiction
here's the basic summary of what
tolerance is first of all
tolerance refers to the reduced effects
of alcohol with repeated exposure
and it is caused mainly by changes in
neurotransmitter systems in the brain
that are the direct consequence of the
toxicity of alcohol that aldehyde
molecule that we talked about before
there's enormous number of chemicals
that change with repeated exposure to
acetylaldehyde
everything from gaba to dopamine to
serotonin second messenger systems
adenosine and on and on rather than go
into each of those in detail i just want
to talk about the contour of the
reinforcing
and the tolerance-inducing effects of
alcohol what do i mean by that well
here we are back to our old friend
meaning the molecule that comes up over
and over again in these podcast episodes
which is dopamine
whether or not somebody has a
predisposition alcoholism or not whether
or not they're experienced drinker or
not when people initially start drinking
there are increases in dopamine or what
we call dopaminergic transmission
dopamine is involved in motivation
craving it creates a sense of well-being
it increases energy again
typically only at the beginning of
alcohol exposure
that occurs in most people as a sharp
spike as they increase again if somebody
does not have alcohol dehydrogenase or
has very low levels of the enzyme that
convert
that acetyl aldehyde into acetate
and metabolize alcohol in other words
they will feel sick and lousy
in a way that will override any
recognition of the dopamine release
they're going to be the people that are
listening to this and just think alcohol
just makes me feel sick i don't like it
okay that's a specific subcategory of
people but most people experience some
sort of mild euphoria that's why so many
people drink right the current estimates
are that in most countries and certainly
in the us as many as 80 percent of the
adult
legal drinking age population drinks
alcohol
and that number could be even higher now
because in the last couple of years
there's been a trend towards increased
alcohol consumption especially in the
wake of the pandemic and during the
pandemic topic for another time
so there's an increase in dopamine and
an increase in serotonin so it's kind of
an increase in well-being and increase
in mood but it's a very short-lived
increase
very soon after and actually triggered
by that increase is a long and slow
reduction
in dopamine and serotonin and related
molecules and circuits so basically what
you're getting is a blip of feel good
followed by a long slow arc of feeling
not so great which is why typically
people will drink again and again across
the night
the key thing to understand about
tolerance is that with tolerance
the
duration of that long slow reduction in
dopamine and serotonin gets even longer
in other words the negative effects of
alcohol that happen after the initial
feeling good
extend longer and in fact get more
robust
however
there's also a reduction
in the reinforcing properties of alcohol
there's a shrinking of the feel-good
blip that happens when one first ingests
alcohol and this has been measured in
animals and humans so the first drink
that somebody has provided they have
enough alcohol dehydrogenase that
doesn't make them feel nauseous and sick
right away they feel really good
and then as it wears off they feel kind
of lousy and they want to drink more so
they might drink more with each
subsequent drink and even drinks on
different nights
or even different weeks the amount of
dopamine that's released
is reduced the amount of serotonin
that's released is reduced so what
you're getting is
less and less of the reinforcing
properties of alcohol
the feel good stuff
and more and more of the punishment pain
signal aspects of alcohol this is the
contour of
chemical
release in the brain that was referred
to by
my colleague the incredible dr anna
lemke who's a medical doctor she wrote
the incredible book dopamine nation she
was a guest on this podcast on joe
rogan's podcast on rich rolls podcast
and several other podcasts world expert
in addiction and she talked about this
pleasure pain balance that extends
beyond alcohol to things like sex and
gambling and to other behaviors that can
potentially become addictive but
certainly includes alcohol so tolerance
it seems is
a process in which people are ingesting
more and more alcohol as an attempt to
get that
feeling of well-being back but what
they're really getting is an extended
period of punishment of pain and of
malaise from the alcohol now you might
say well how does that relate to
tolerance well it turns out what they do
behaviorally and when i say they i mean
animals do this and humans do this is
they start drinking more and more in an
attempt to activate those dopamine and
serotonin neurons and receptors
and
as they do that there is an increase in
alcohol dehydrogenase so the enzyme that
metabolizes alcohol is increased because
the body and liver have to contend with
all that alcohol
so now you've got again the two-hit
model you're getting less of the
feel-good chemicals more of the negative
chemical release or pattern of
of subjective feeling i should say and
you're metabolizing alcohol more quickly
and more readily but it's not taking you
to a better place in terms of how you
feel that's one of the major underlying
reasons for what we call tolerance so if
you're somebody who drinks and you
notice that the feeling that you are
seeking with alcohol
is now requiring an additional drink or
drinks plural chances are you are
disrupting the dopamine and serotonergic
systems of your brain
and you are doing that in a way that is
increasing the
pain and punishment signals
that
follow alcohol ingestion and again
that's not just on the night that you're
drinking but afterwards as well
is that all bad news well pretty much
but the good news is that if you abstain
from drinking for some period of time
then of course these systems reset how
long you need to abstain will depend on
how much you were drinking and how long
you were drinking for certainly people
who have alcohol use disorder who are
alcoholics their main goal should be to
quit alcohol completely i know there's
some debate about this and i don't want
to get into that debate because i'm
certainly not i'm going to try and
direct anyone's recovery their expert
counselors and mds and people that can
work with people in fact for some very
heavy drinkers and people with serious
alcohol use disorder going cold turkey
that is stopping drinking completely can
actually be medically dangerous so
the path to sobriety for certain people
looks different than the path to
sobriety for other people what i'm
referring to here are people that are
ingesting again somewhere between on
average one to two drinks per night
whether or not that's done night to
night or whether or not that's condensed
to weekend use i know a number of people
are going to ask perhaps are screaming
is drinking good for me in any way for
instance many people have probably heard
that resveratrol is good for people that
red wine is enriched in resveratrol
i hate to break it to you but the
reality is that
if indeed resveratrol is good for us and
there's some debate about this some
people say strongly yes some people say
no other people say maybe
the amount of red wine that one would
have to drink
in order to get enough resveratrol in
order for it to be health promoting is
so outrageously high that it would
surely induce other negative effects
that would offset the positive effects
of resveratrol so i wish i could tell
you different again i'm not here to be
the bearer of bad news but the statement
i just made was confirmed by dr david
sinclair when he was a guest on this
podcast it's confirmed by other
researchers who work on resveratrol and
related pathways
i wish i could tell you that red wine is
good for your health and indeed it might
be
through some other mechanisms so for
instance there have been studies of low
to moderate red wine consumption
this would be anywhere from one to four
glasses per week and i don't mean
enormous glasses i mean six ounce
glasses of red wine
and in those cases some of the stress
reduction that can be induced by
consumption of red wine maybe some of
the other micronutrients and components
within red wines in particular red wines
that come from particular grapes and
this gets really nuanced and frankly is
not well worked out in the peer-reviewed
literature certainly not
clinical trials at least not that i'm
aware of tell me if you're aware of a
great clinical trial on this well there
may be some positive effects of that
very low level of consumption
i'm not trying to take away anybody's
red wine i'm not trying to
take away anybody's anything i
would be remiss however if i didn't tell
you that
resveratrol as the argument for drinking
and drinking red wine in particular is
just not a good one it's just not
supported by the peer-reviewed research
a few other things about
alcohol and health the beginning of the
episode i referenced a study showing
that
indeed not just heavy alcohol
consumption of 12 to 24 or more drinks
per week but also light to moderate
alcohol consumption of any type wine
beer spirits etc
does reduce the thickness of
the brain it really does reduce cortical
thickness in fact it actually scales
with the amount of alcohol that people
drink
and
this has been well documented in a
number of different studies i can
provide a link to several of these
one of the more striking ones actually
shows that there's almost a
dose-dependent
increase in shrinkage of gray matter
volume and in these white matter tracks
these uh axons these wires as it would
that connect different neurons as a
function of how much alcohol people
drink and that's also what's been seen
in this recent study that i referenced
at the beginning and that's in the show
note captions so again probably the best
amount of alcohol to drink would be zero
glasses per week or ounces per week
for those of you drinking low amounts of
alcohol make sure you're doing other
things to promote your health
and for those of you that are drinking
moderate and certainly for those of you
that are heavy drinkers please do
everything you can to move away from
that and to quit entirely but even for
the moderate
consumers of alcohol you are going to
want to be aware of some of the negative
health effects and do things to offset
those if indeed you're not going to stop
drinking
or reduce your intake one of the really
bad effects of alcohol but that's
extremely well documented
is the fact
that alcohol because of this toxicity of
acetyl aldehyde and related pathways
can alter dna methylation it can alter
gene expression that can be many things
in different tissues
but it is
associated with a
significant increase in cancer risk in
particular breast cancer and in
particular because breast tissue is
present in both males and females but
in women it's especially vulnerable to
some of the dna methylation changes
well breast cancer in women has a
relationship to alcohol intake and
alcohol intake has a relationship to
breast cancer in women
in fact
there
has been proposed to be a
anywhere from 4 to 13 increase in risk
of breast cancer for every 10 grams of
alcohol consumed how much is 10 grams
well there we need to think a little bit
about the variation in the amount of
alcohol in different drinks across the
world different countries serve
different size drinks and have different
concentrations of alcohol in those
drinks so without going down too much of
a rabbit hole and just giving you some
good rules of thumb to work with
there have been studies of the
percentage of alcohol including
different drinks and the sizes of
different drinks that are served in
different countries and here's a kind of
a patchwork of of those findings
in japan
one beer
one glass of wine or one shot of liquor
as it served there
tends to include anywhere from seven to
eight grams of alcohol in the u.s one
beer which generally is 12 ounces
if it's in a bottle
one glass of wine or a shot of liquor
tends to include about 10 to 12 grams of
alcohol
and
in russia
one drink of the various source that i
just described
typically will have as much as 24 grams
of alcohol because of the differences in
the concentration of alcohols
and the sizes of drinks that are poured
in these different countries okay of
course there are other countries in the
world those countries are also vitally
important but those are the ones that
extracted from the studies
that i could find
what does this mean well what we're
talking about is that for every 10 grams
of alcohol consumed so that's one beer
in the u.s
maybe a little bit more than one beer in
japan or
basically a third of a drink in russia
there's a 4 to 13 increase
in risk of
cancer
that's pretty outrageous right and you
might think wait how could it be that
you know this stuff is even legal well
look it's as i described before it's a
toxin it's also a toxin that people
enjoy the effects of i mean in the u.s
at least they tried prohibition um it
certainly did lead
yes did lead to a reduction in alcohol
induced health disorders in particular
cirrhosis of the liver it also led to a
lot of crime because it became a
substance that a lot of people still
wanted and that people were willing to
break the law in order to provide or i
should say to sell and provide but the
point is that the more alcohol people
drink
the greater their increase of cancer in
particular breast cancer and that's
because of the fact that alcohol has
these effects on cells that include
changes in gene expression and cancer
that is the growth of tumors is a
dysregulation in cell cycles right a
tumor is a aggregation or the
proliferation aggregation is stuff
sticking together by the way
proliferation is stuff
duplicating a proliferation aggregation
of cells
that could be a gliomas glial cells
glioma brain tumor right it could be
lymphoma so within the lymph tissue etc
the mutations that alcohol induces to
cause this are wide-ranging some of
those are starting to start to be
understood for those of you that are
interested in cell biology i'll just
mention that the pd1 pathway again this
is
super
specialized and for the aficionados only
you don't need to know this the pd-1
pathway seems to be upregulated and
and we knew this from the discussion
earlier there's a down regulation in
some of the
anti-inflammatory molecules
that help suppress
this proliferation of cancers nowadays
there's a lot of interest in the fact
that the immune system is constantly
combating cancers that exist in us all
the time you know little little tumors
start growing and our immune system goes
and gobbles them up little tumors start
growing the immune system senses
inflammation sends out these incredible
cells these killers b cells and t cells
and and and beats them up
cancers proliferate and take hold and
cause serious problems when the
proliferation of cells exceeds the
immune system's ability to gobble up and
remove those cells there are other
mechanisms of regulating cancers but
that's one of the primary one and
alcohol hits it again it's a two-hit
model it increases tumor growth and
it decreases the sorts of molecules that
suppress and combat tumor growth
so again
even low to moderate amounts of alcohol
can be problematic for sake of cancers
in particular breast cancers
epidemiologists and
health specialists love to try and
compare different substances in terms of
how bad they are rarely do they compare
substances in terms of how good they are
but sometimes they do
and
what they'll sometimes tell you and what
you can find in the literature is that
ingesting 10 to 15 grams of alcohol a
day so that would be like one beer in
the u.s one glass of wine is the same as
smoking 10 cigarettes a day
frankly it's hard to make that direct
relationship really stick because you
know it's a question of you know how
long people inhale do they have a
predisposition to a lung cancer etc but
even if that number is off
by
plus or minus two cigarettes or
even if that number would the equivalent
of one glass of wine equals one
cigarette per day i think there's
general consensus now that
nicotine consumed by vaping or by
cigarette it's
bad for
us in terms of lung cancer and other
forms of cancer and
for some reason i don't know why because
this knowledge about alcohol and cancer
and these
established relationships have been
known since the late 1980s the first you
know landmark paper on this was
published in 1987. i can provide a link
to that paper it's actually quite
interesting
to read
well
the
relationship is there and yet we don't
often hear about it right in fact in
before researching this episode i had
heard before that alcohol can increase
cancer risk but i wasn't aware of just
how strong that relationship is because
of the serious nature of what we're
talking about and
because i would hate to be
confusing or misleading to anybody i
want to just emphasize that this
statistic that there is a 4 to 13
percent depending on which study you
look at a 4 to 13 percent increase in
the risk of cancer in particular breast
cancer for every 10 grams of alcohol
consumed that's 10 grams per day so
that's one drink per day
but i do want to emphasize that
if that equates to seven drinks per week
and all those seven drinks are being
consumed on friday and saturday it still
averages to 10 grams per day and i also
want to emphasize that there are things
that people can do to at least partially
offset some of the negative effects of
alcohol as it relates to
predisposition to the formation of
certain kinds of tumors and cancers
i also want to be clear before i say it
that doing the things i'm about to tell
you is not a guarantee that you're not
going to get cancer nor is it a
guarantee that alcohol is not going to
lead to an increased
predisposition for certain kinds of
cancers and the two things are
consumption of folate and other b
vitamins especially b12
you know the the consumption of folate
and b12
has been shown to decrease cancer risk
in people that ingest alcohol but not
completely offset it
why that is isn't exactly clear it
probably has something to do with the
relationship between folate and b12 and
other b vitamins in gene regulation
pathways that can lead to tumor growth
at some point soon we will get an expert
in cancer biology and in particular in
breast cancer biology
on the program and we can ask them about
this
but i realize this is going to raise a
number of questions and maybe even cause
some of you to go out there and start
taking folate and other
b vitamins and b12
not incidentally
a lot of the reported
hangover supplements and treatments hap
include folate and b12 i don't know if
they had the cancer literature in mind
when they created those supplements and
and products i doubt they did
alcohol really does disrupt b vitamin
pathways both synthesis pathways and
utilization pathways so sometimes you'll
hear oh you know if you get your b
vitamins it helps you recover from from
hangover
more quickly again the literature
doesn't support that but also again
there aren't a lot of studies but more
to the point as it relates to
alcohol and the formation of tumors and
cancers it does appear
that decreased folate and other
b vitamins like b12 are partially
responsible for
the effect of alcohol and increasing
cancer risk and it does appear that
consuming
adequate amounts of folate in b12 might
again might partially really want to
bold face and underline and highly
partially offset some of that increased
risk there's an additional category that
i want to highlight of course and this
is
vitally important to state even though
it's obvious which is that
people who are pregnant
should absolutely not consume alcohol
fetal alcohol syndrome is
well known and established it's terrible
fetuses
experience
diminished brain development that's
often permanent diminished limb
development diminished organ development
in the periphery meaning the heart the
lungs the liver etc
ingesting alcohol while pregnant is
simply a bad idea and the reason i say
this at all is
first of all it's important to include
in an episode like this but also
because
we can look at two things first of all
we can look at mechanism and then we can
also look at some of the lore
that still sadly exists out there let's
take care of the lore that sadly exists
first
if you look online you will sometimes be
able to find
sadly
that
some people believe that certain kinds
of alcohol are not detrimental to
fetuses they'll say well champagne is
safe for a pregnant mother to drink but
beer is not that is absolutely
categorically false alcohol is alcohol
there is no evidence whatsoever that
consuming certain types of alcohol is
safer for fetuses than others alcohol is
a toxin and the reason fetal alcohol
syndrome exists is because the ability
of that toxin to disrupt cellular
processes
remember tumor growth and the way that
alcohol can accelerate tumor growth by
proliferation of cells the wrong cells
the ones you don't want to proliferate
well all of embryonic development all of
fetal development
it's not the growth of a tumor it's
obviously the growth of an embryo and
it's done in a very orchestrated way
i started off studying brain development
that's where i got my beginnings in
neurobiology and i still teach
embryology to medical students and
graduate students
the
set of coordinated processes that has to
take place from conception to birth in
order to give rise to a healthy embryo
is so
so dynamically controlled and so
exquisitely precise with checkpoints and
recovery mechanisms and redundancy in
the genes that are expressed to make
sure that if anything goes wrong it's
repaired etc
alcohol as a mutagen
i haven't used that word yet but a
substance that can mutate dna through
alterations in dna methylation and these
checkpoints in the cell cycle alcohol as
a mutagen
is one of the worst things that a
developing embryo can be exposed to and
again because it's water soluble and fat
soluble ingestion of alcohol when people
are pregnant passes right to the fetus
now i realize that a number of people
out there might be thinking oh goodness
you know i didn't realize i was pregnant
until a certain stage of pregnancy and
before i realized i was ingesting
alcohol
obviously
one can't undo what's been done but i
want to also emphasize that fetal
alcohol syndrome while yes there's a
full-blown syndrome that manifests as
changes in the craniofacial development
that are very obvious and you can look
these up you've probably seen these
before the pictures before rather it has
to do with eye spacing forehead size a
number of other features of the
craniofacial development
and of course stuff's going on in the
brain too it's along a continuum
so it is possible that some of the
changes that occur
are more minor and thankfully the young
brain in particular the early postnatal
brain is incredibly plastic there are
things that can be done in order to help
recover neural circuits that didn't
develop well etc but
even though it's somewhat obvious or
should be obvious i really want to make
clear that there's zero evidence
whatsoever that certain forms of alcohol
are safer for pregnant women to ingest
in others absolutely wrong no one who's
pregnant should be ingesting alcohol
whatsoever
and certainly if people feel like they
can't avoid alcohol while pregnant they
really need to work with somebody to
make sure that it just absolutely
doesn't happen because it's so
detrimental to the developing fetus
lastly i want to talk about the effects
of alcohol on hormones and i want to
distinguish between
low amounts of alcohol intake higher
amounts of alcohol intake and again this
chronic alcohol intake versus occasional
use versus
really chronic use meaning
alcoholic or alcoholic use disorder
where people are drinking an immense
amount on an ongoing basis the
literature on alcohol and hormones is
quite extensive and there are of course
many many different types of hormones
the hormones that most often get
mentioned and talked about on this
podcast are the hormones testosterone
and estrogen which are present in both
men and women that in both men and women
are important for things like
libido
they're also responsible for sexual
development actual development of the
genitalia before birth and after birth
they're responsible for instance
estrogen is important for memory and
cognition you never want to drop
estrogen too low in men or women because
it can disrupt cognition and joint
health etc
to keep this discussion relatively
constrained it's fair to say that
alcohol
and in particular the toxic metabolites
of alcohol
increase the conversion of testosterone
to estrogen
now
this occurs in a number of different
tissues this is not just occurring in
the testes of males this is occurring in
lots of different tissues and i'll refer
you to a excellent review we'll provide
a link in the show note captions this is
a
paper that was published in the year
2000 but the data are still
quite strong the journal is called of
all things alcohol
there's yes literally a journal called
alcohol for the publication of data and
reviews on alcohol and its effects and
the title of the paper is can alcohol
promote aromatization of androgens to
estrogens aromatization is this process
of the conversion of testosterone and
other androgens to estrogens through
things like aromatase enzyme and
this is a beautiful review that
describes every tissue
or near every tissue from the ovary and
females to the placenta to the liver to
the testes in which alcohol
can increase the aromatization of
testosterone and estrogen now in females
this may be part of the reason why
there's an increase in estrogen-related
cancers breast cancer can be either
estrogen related or non-estrogen related
there are other types of estrogen
related cancers outside of breast cancer
but it appears that one reason why
alcohol increases the risk of breast
cancer is because of this aromatization
from of testosterone excuse me to
estrogen
in males
accelerated or
abnormal conversion of testosterone
estrogen can actually lead to growth of
the breast tissue in males so called
gynecomastia or other effects of high
estrogen or i should say of altered
testosterone estrogen ratios because
that's really what's important
and these can include things like
diminished sex drive increased fat
storage and a number of other things
that i think most people
would find to be negative effects
i once talked about the fact that
drinking alcohol can increase the
aromaization of testosterone to estrogen
i posted that online and i didn't get
attacked but i did
get criticized for the fact that it has
been shown yes has been shown that small
amounts of alcohol ingestion so five
grams or so of alcohol injections would
be half a glass of wine or half a glass
of beer at least in some studies showed
increases in testosterone which was kind
of surprising but i should point out
other studies have shown that alcohol
ingestion causes decreases in
testosterone
over time so there's always this issue
whether or not you're looking at study
of acute exposure versus chronic
exposure you know one dose versus
multiple doses and exposure
i think it's fair to say based on my
read of the literature this review and
other reviews that focus more
particularly on humans that
regular ingestion of alcohol is going to
increase
estrogen levels whether or not you're
male or female and it's largely doing
that through the aromatization process
by increasing the aromatase enzyme
yes there's some dose dependence but i
think if you're somebody who's trying to
optimize your testosterone to estrogen
ratio regardless of whether or not
you're male or female well then most
certainly you're going to want to avoid
drinking too much alcohol so we've
covered a lot of topics and data related
to the mechanisms of alcohol hangover
tolerance
cancer risk etc i acknowledge that i've
mainly talked to you about the negative
effects of alcohol
i want to acknowledge that
many people enjoy alcohol in
moderation or even light drinking the
occasional drink or the occasional two
drinks or maybe even on average one
drink per night so seven drinks per week
i'm certainly not here to tell you what
to do and what not to do
i do find it immensely interesting
however
that first of all alcohol is a known
toxin to the cells of the body some of
you might immediately say well wait what
about hormesis what about this
phenomenon where if we regularly ingest
a toxin it makes us stronger in other
words what doesn't kill us makes us
stronger
there's you know some reason to believe
that might be beneficial in terms of
some forms of seller resilience maybe
maybe no
sorry it doesn't work that way there are
processes of hormesis in which for
instance exposing yourself
safely to increases in adrenaline
through you know ice baths or other
things that increase adrenaline can
raise your so-called stress threshold
but here we're talking about cellular
stress and damage to cells
so my read of the literature and again
this is my read and i invite others to
you know provide studies or i would
prefer actually collections of studies
that point in the direction if they
exist
that
alcohol can be beneficial but my read of
the literature
or i should say my understanding of what
i would call the center of mass of the
literature on alcohol
is that
no consumption zero consumption
consumption of zero ounces of alcohol
is going to be better for your health
than low to moderate consumption of
alcohol
and that low to moderate consumption of
alcohol is going to be better for you of
course than moderately high to high
alcohol consumption on the order of 12
to 24 or more drinks
per week
i realized that for most people
listening to this it's probably low to
moderate alcohol consumption that is
part of their standard repertoire
and i'm not here to give you
justification for doing that nor am i
going to tell you not to do that i would
like you to consider perhaps however the
negative effects that we understand and
that are documented for instance the
negative effects of alcohol and the gut
microbiome and the things that you can
do to better support your gut microbiome
the negative effects on the stress
system that hpa axis that we talked
about earlier and the fact that even low
to moderate levels of alcohol
consumption can increase our levels of
stress when we're not drinking
and to think about
acquiring some tools and you know
getting some proficiency with tools
behavioral or otherwise that can help
you with stress modulation that don't
involve alcohol consumption again
the point here is to illustrate where
the problems lie with alcohol
consumption but also
what i've tried to do is to point you to
some resources that can help offset some
of those negative effects will they
offset all the effects
i can't say that for sure but certainly
taking measures
to offset some of the negative effects
of any alcohol consumption that you
might
be having or doing is going to be
beneficial to you and those tools and
protocols are going to be health
promoting in any case if you're learning
from and or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our youtube channel that's
a terrific zero-cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on spotify and on apple and on
both spotify and apple you can leave us
up to a five-star review if you have
questions for us about the content
covered on the podcast or suggestions of
topics you'd like us to cover or guests
that you'd like us to host on the
huberman lab podcast please include all
of that in the comments section on
youtube we do read all the comments
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning of today's
podcast and check out momentous
supplements our new partners in the
supplement space and check out athletic
greens that's the best way to support
this podcast if you're not already
following us on social media please do
so we are huberman lab on twitter and we
are also huberman lab on instagram and
both places i cover science and science
related tools some of which overlap with
the content of the huberman lab podcast
but much of which is unique from the
content covered on the huberman lab
podcast again that's huberman lab on
instagram and huberman lab on twitter
please also check out our neural network
monthly newsletter this is a newsletter
that has summaries of podcast episodes
it also includes a lot of actionable
protocols it's very easy to sign up for
the newsletter you go to hubermanlab.com
click on the menu go to newsletter you
supply your email but we do not share
your email with anybody we have a very
clear and rigorous privacy policy which
is we do not share your email with
anybody and the newsletter comes out
once a month and it is completely zero
cost again just go to hubermanlab.com
and go to the neural network newsletter
i'd also like to point out that the
huberman lab podcast has a clips channel
so these are brief clips anywhere from
three to ten minutes that encompass
single concepts and actionable protocols
related to sleep to focus
interviews with various guests we talk
about things like caffeine when to drink
caffeine relative to sleep
alcohol when and how and if anyone
should ingest it relative to sleep
dopamine serotonin mental health
physical health and on and on all the
things that relate to the topics most of
interest to you you can find that easily
by going to youtube look for huberman
lab clips in the search area and it will
take you there subscribe and we are
constantly updating those with new clips
this is especially useful i believe for
people that have missed some of the
earlier episodes or you're still working
through the back catalog of hebrew lab
podcast which admittedly can be rather
long and last but certainly not least
thank you for your interest in science